[Music]  how many upcoming weddings are you  attending it seems 2021 is shaping up to  be the year of rescheduled  nuptials according to the wedding  planning website the knot  the number of couples ordering save the  date announcements more than tripled at  the start of this year compared to the  fall  but even with restrictions rolling back  there are some pandemic factors couples  and guests still need to consider  prior to the ceremony follow your cdc  guidelines  follow your local and state guidelines  and think about things you can do to  make your guests feel more comfortable  put that information on your wedding  website let them know if you're wearing  masks if you're mandating vaccines  that will make everyone feel a little  safer when they're celebrating  also something to keep in mind with so  many rescheduled ceremonies  intense competition for venues and  services wedding planners say couples  need to be creative  and also flexible christian